The latest modern malware is APT,
or advanced persistent threat.
They tend to target
specific organizations,
while as botnets tend to have
bots all over the internet.
APT is advanced, which means
that is uses special malware.
Sometimes, the malware is
specifically crafted for
the targeted organization, but very
often the malware's actually a special
version of a common malware that
has to be used in other botnets.
By starting from a common malware,
the attackers behind APT's want to
have both convenience and deniability.
That is, security admins would not
suspect that the malware is APT.
They would think that this is a new
version of the common malware.
Advance can also mean
special operations.
That is, APT is not used for
common attacks and
frauds, such as spamming and
click fraud or phishing.
Rather, it can be used for
very high value operations, such as
stealing the design of a new airplane.
APT's persistent, meaning that once
the malware gets into an organization,
it's going to stay there for
a long time.
And it typically
involves multiple steps.
Each step is low and
slow, to avoid detection.
For example, one of them sending
out the design of the airplane,
which is a large volume of
data to the internet at once.
The APT can break the data
into multiple chunks.
And then it can sent each
chunk to the internet,
whenever there is a user connecting
to the internet, that is,
the transmission of each chunk of
data will not raise any suspicion.
APT is a very dangerous threat because,
as we have discussed,
APTs tend to target high value
organizations and information.